les soignons espagnol se mobilisent les
membres du collectif de santé sanitarios
ce n'est ses sérieuses se sont
rassemblés à madrid ce lundi une action
pour protester contre la gestion de
l'hôpital isabelle sandales inauguré le
1er décembre dernier la communauté de
madrid a notamment recours aux
transferts de personnels soignants vers
cet établissement une stratégie à
laquelle s'opposent les manifestants les
représentants de ce collectif dénonce
également la détérioration du système de
santé espagnol ils n'ont pas honte parce
la première vague
on sort de la deuxième et la troisième
arrive et pour l'économie l'emportent
sur la santé les soins primaires ne se
sont guère améliorées les centres de
santé ne peuvent pas fournir
d'assistance car ils continuent d'être
abandonnés et les services d'urgence et
de soins primaires continuent d'être
fermé une mobilisation qui intervient
alors que la situation sanitaire en
espagne reste préoccupante
le pays a dépassé la barre symbolique
des 50 mille mordu coronavirus dans ce
contexte le gouvernement mis sur la
campagne de vaccination qui a débuté ce
dimanche pour assurer le suivi
le ministre de la santé a annoncé la
mise en place d'un registre qui
recensera les personnes refusant de se
faire vacciner
le registre kovy 19 est une mesure de
prudence dans tout processus de
vaccination
il est très utile de disposer des
données pour pouvoir effectuer un
processus de pharmacovigilance afin de
réaliser les études pertinentes et 7
enregistrée qui à cette finalité
il est aussi vrai que tous les
organismes internationaux et européens
recommandent que nous disposons de
données et qu'une partagions entre nous
les informations de pharmacovigilance
sur le processus de vaccination et face
à la crise sanitaire de nombreuses
restrictions de déplacement reste en
vigueur dans plusieurs régions
espagnoles avec plus de 1,8 million de
cas de kovy détectée l'espagne reste
l'un des pays européens les plus
durement touchées par la pandémie